GONNA. VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. RIGHT YES
HERE MATHIS YOUR ARAMBULA
PRESENT FLORA. FRIEDMAN GIPSON
YOUR MAIENSCHEIN. STONE. THANK
YOU AND WELCOME TO THE MAY
SEVENTH HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE TODAY
WE HAVE FOURTEEN BILLS SEVEN OF
THOSE ARE ON CONSENT. TO START
I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL OF THE
STUFF THAT MADE POSSIBLE ARE
RETURNED TO THE CAPITAL. AND
OUR ABILITY TO MAXIMIZE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PARTICIPATION
IN OUR HEARINGS. I'D ALSO LIKE
TO NOTE THAT DUE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE'S DECISION NOT TO
DOUBLE REFER BILLS I MADE ARE
ADJUSTED HEARING SCHEDULE.
SEVERAL OF THE ANALYSES FOR
TODAY'S HEARING INCLUDE
STATEMENTS FROM POLICY
COMMITTEES IN ORDER TO ALLOW
FOR COMMENTS OR CONCERNS WITH A
PARTICULAR BILL TO BE ENTERED
INTO THE PUBLIC RECORD. TO THAT
END I WILL NOW SHARE A FEW
NOTES ABOUT THE LOGISTICS OF
OUR HEARING. REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION TO HELP PRESERVE
THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE
TODAY AND ASSURE THE PUBLIC
SAYS ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION.
TO THE CURRENT STATE HOME ORDER
WE ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND TO THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. SO WE ARE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON. WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY
TODAY. FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM. WE'RE HAVING A PHYSICALLY
DISTANT IN PERSON HEARING IN
THIS SPACE WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE UP TO ELEVEN
MEMBERS AT A MINIMAL CONTINGENT
OF STAFF AND A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PUBLIC AND MEDIA. SO WE CAN
MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF SPACING.
FOR OUR DIAL IN A WITNESSES.
WILL BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING. IS. 877-692-8957
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN
TO DO SO AS THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL YOUR TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON%
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU%
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN Q. BASED ON WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL.
IF YOU WERE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST. AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND IT DISTORTION. PLEASE
ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE
AT THE MAIN WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST THE
BILL YOU WILL REMAIN ON A LIVE
LINE AND WILL NEED TO PLEASE
MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE
CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT AREA CODE
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE
TWO ZERO EIGHT NINE AND MY
STAFF WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO
HELP. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT
WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. WE HAVE SEVEN MEASURES ON
CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER TWO. AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY. ITEM
NUMBER FIVE. AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTEEN TING. ITEM SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY THREE QUIRK
SILVA. ITEM NINE AB THIRTY
SEVENTY THREE WORKS. ITEM TEN
THIRTY TO THIRTY EIGHT SMITH.
ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY NINE
FORTY FOUR MARK STONE AND ITEM
FOURTEEN AB. THIRTY TWO SEVENTY
TWO RADIOS DO I HAVE A MOTION.
WHAT WE'VE MOTION. AND WE HAVE
A SECOND ON THE MOTION. PLEASE
TAKE THEIR OWN. RAY YES HI RES
HI MATHIS MATHIS HI ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI FLORA FLORA I
FRIEDMAN REMAIN HIGH GIPSON IT
SAID I. MAIENSCHEIN STONE STONE
I. THE CALL IS SEVEN TWO ZERO.
THANK YOU WILL LEAVE THE RECORD
OPEN FOR OUR ABSENCE MEMBER.
ALL RIGHT LET'S BEGIN ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER. WELCOME TO. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS-
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
FOUR WHICH WOULD AUTHORIZE YUBA
AND SUTTER COUNTIES TO FORM A
JOINT HOMELESS MULTI
DISCIPLINARY PERSONNEL TEAM-
THE TEAM WOULD FACILITATE
INFORMATION SHARING- TO SUPPORT
THE IDENTIFICATION ASSESSMENT
AND LINKAGE OF HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS TO HOUSING AND
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES ANDY TEAS
ARE PROVEN TOOL THAT ALLOWED
TEAMS FROM A VARIETY OF
DISCIPLINES TO COORDINATE THEIR
EFFORTS AND EIGHTY HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY USED FOR THE PAST
THIRTY YEARS TO ADDRESS CHILD
ABUSE OR NEGLECT. ALLOWING
COUNTY SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
WORK TOGETHER TO SHARE CASE
INFORMATION MOST RECENTLY ANDY
TIAS A MAN USED TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. UNFORTUNATELY
CURRENT LAW LIMITS THE
UTILIZATION OF HOMELESS NDTV'S
TWO PROVIDERS WITHIN A SINGLE
COUNTY. THIS CAN BE PROBLEMATIC
FOR COUNTIES THAT WISH TO
BETTER COORDINATE SERVICES
ACROSS COUNTY LINES FOR THEIR
HOMELESS POPULATIONS LIKE YUBA
AND SUTTER COUNTIES YUBA AND
SUTTER COUNTIES ARE ADJACENT TO
EACH OTHER- THERE COUNTY SEATS
YUBA CITY IN MARYSVILLE OR-
BORDER ON THE FEATHER RIVER
ACROSS FROM EACH OTHER- AND
THEY HAVE MANY DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS ARE ACTUALLY BY COUNTY
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH IS B
COUNTY- THERE- IN JUVENILE HALL
AS BY COUNTY AND SO THERE'S
MANY DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THEY
ALREADY OPERATE TOGETHER. ON A
BY COUNTY BASIS BECAUSE OF
THEIR UNIQUE TO YOU GEOGRAPHY-
THE HOMELESS POPULATION IN THIS
AREA FREQUENTLY MOVES- ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE RIVER- IN BETWEEN
THESE TWO COMMUNITIES. YUBA AND
SUTTER COUNTIES- AS I SAID OF
CREATED BY COUNTY SERVICES
PROGRAM FOR IT FOR GENERAL
PLANNING. OF REGIONAL
HOMELESSNESS EVER EFFORTS AND
TO UNIFY PROPOSED INITIATIVES-
PART OF THIS EFFORT INCLUDES
EXPANDING AND UNIFYING THE
COUNTY'S HOMELESS ENGAGEMENT
AND RESOLUTION TEAMS. WHICH ARE
CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW TO SEPARATE
COUNTY TEAMS COORDINATION AND
INFORMATION SHARING MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE FOR THESE COUNTIES AS
A ALREADY SHARE HOMELESS
SERVICE PROVIDERS HAVE A BY
COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENT. AND
HAVE CREATED A BY COUNTY
HOMELESS CONSORTIUM. SO AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE WOULD
HELP THESE EFFORTS. TO PROVIDE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT OF SERVICES
TO HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS- WHICH
ARE ESPECIALLY CRITICAL TO
CONTAINING- COVERT NINETEEN.
ARE HOMELESS POPULATION IS
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE DURING
THIS CRISIS. SO INCREASE
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE
COUNTIES WOULD ALSO CREATE COST
SAVINGS AND IMPROVE GOVERNMENT
EFFICIENCY EFFICIENCY BY
PREVENTING DUPLICATIVE EFFORTS
THE BETTER COORDINATION. AND SO
THIS WOULD BE A VERY HELPFUL
AND USEFUL TOOL FOR THESE
COUNTY TO ALREADY WORKING
TOGETHER IN MANY DIFFERENT WAYS
AND WITH ME TO TESTIFY ON THE
PHONE ARE MARKS LET'S MEYER THE
ADULT SERVICES BRANCH DIRECTOR
FOR SUTTER COUNTY. HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AND CHI AGO
EASY- THE YUBA COUNTY CAL WORKS
HOMELESS PROJECT MANAGER. Q.
AND I'D ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
GIFFORD FIRST WITNESS MISTER
SCHULTZ MEYER. HI MARKS BUT
FIRE- THEY DON'T SERVICES
BRANCH DIRECTOR FOR START
COUNTY HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES- THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS FOR PROVIDING THIS
TIME TO IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSED DAHLE I'D LIKE TO JUST
PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT MORE
BACKGROUND ON THE BY COUNTY HOW
MUCH EFFORT THAT'S CURRENTLY
HAPPENING IN SOUTHERN YUBA
COUNTY. ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
THE CA AS IF YOU'VE BEEN SUTTER
COUNTY. CAME TOGETHER TO CREATE
A BY COUNTY HOW MUCH
PARTNERSHIP. THERE'S A
LEADERSHIP GROUP HAS GATHERED
ON A MONTHLY BASIS. TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR REGION- IT
CONSISTS OF BOARD OF SUPERVISOR
REPRESENTATIVES FOR BOTH YUBA
AND SUTTER COUNTY. AS WELL AS
CITY COUNCIL REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE CITIES OF THE YUBA
CITY MARYVILLE AND WE WENT. AS
WELL AS THE CA OF THE BOTH
SUTTER AND YUBA COUNTIES. SO
THAT'SGOOD THIS COLLABORATIVE
BY COUNTY GROUP HAS BEEN
COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS AS A REGIONAL
ISSUE. AND IS CONSTANTLY
STRIVING TO CREATE A BALANCE OF
STRONG SERVICES AND SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE RIVER. THAT
DIVIDES OUR TO COUNTY. ONE OF
THE MAJOR TASKS AT THE BY
COUNTY HOMES PARTNERSHIP IS
TAKEN ON IS TO CREATE SUB
COMMITTEES. TO ADDRESS-
REGIONAL HOMELESSNESS AND AS A
FAMILY MAN GALLAGHER POINTED
OUT WE HAVE A- A SUBCOMMITTEE
FOCUSED ON A HOMELESS OUTREACH-
AND ENFORCEMENT TEAM CALLED
HEART TEAM THAT- THE HOMELESS
ENGAGEMENT RESOLUTION TEAM
ACTUALLY- THIS CAME COMBINED
SOCIAL SERVICES. BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND ENFORCEMENT STAFF
MEMBERS INTO ONE. REGIONAL WHAT
THAT MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAM.
AND THE TEAM PROVIDE IT WILL
THE TEAM IS GOING TO BE
PROVIDING EXTENSIVE SUPPORT AND
LINKAGE TO SERVICES IN AN
EFFORT TO. PROVIDE WHAT WE CALL
CAN COMPASSIONATE AND CODE
ENFORCEMENT. SO BUT COUNTIES IN
ALL FOUR OF THE MAJOR
MUNICIPALITIES HAVE NOW
APPROVED A SHARED AND- YOU.
THAT WILL ALLOW THIS MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM. TO OPERATE
IN ALL JURISDICTIONS. THE BILL
FOR. A CRITICAL PIECE OF THE
WORK THAT THIS TEAM WILL DO AS
WITH OTHER MULTI DISCIPLINARY
TEAM THE ABILITY TO SHARE.
MINIMAL BASIC INFORMATION AMONG
TEAM MEMBERS OF THE CENTRAL TO
ACCOMPLISHING THE TEAM'S
MISSION- AND AS YOU'RE AWARE
HOMELESSNESS IS A VERY COMPLEX
ISSUE TO ADDRESS AND
COMMUNICATION AMONG THOSE
TRYING TO SOLVE IT. IS A BASIC
REQUIREMENT FOR SUCCESS. ARE TO
CARRY TO PLACE THE A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF EFFORT SO FAR INTO
OUR COOPERATIVE APPROACH AND
WITHOUT PASSAGE OF THIS BILL
WILL BE VERY DIFFICULT TO
ACCOMPLISH OUR MISSION OF
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS. IN OUR
REGION SO I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. Q. KAYAK ELISE YEAH. AND
I REMIND OUR WITNESSES THAT
WE'RE LIMITED TO TWO MINUTES
PER WITNESS. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M I'M
PAYING AT LEAST YOU HAVE THE
PROJECT MANAGER FOR HOMELESS
AND HOUSING INITIATIVES AND
YUBA COUNTY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO BRING THE
AUTHORIZATION OF A BY COUNTY
HOMELESS MULTI DISCIPLINARY
TEAM. THE TEAM THAT'S UNDER
DEVELOPMENT IS IN DIRECT
RESPONSE TO A LOCAL NEED THAT
HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED REGARDING
COORDINATION OF CARE AND
CONTINUATION OF SERVICES. ARE
AREAS HAD RECOGNIZED CONTINUUM
OF CARE IS THE SUTTER YUBA
HOMELESS CONSORTIUM WHICH WAS
FORMALIZED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX. SINCE THAT TIME THE
CONSORTIUM HAS SERVED BOTH YOU
BY ANSWER COUNTIES WITH THE
MISSION OF REDUCING DUPLICATION
OF EFFORT AND INCREASING
COMMUNICATION AMONG HOMELESS
SERVICE AGENCIES. AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY FOUR FALLS IN LINE WITH
THE VISION OF OUR FIELD FEET
THAT EVERYONE HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A SAFE
PLACE TO CALL HOME. THE
HOMELESS POPULATION AND EVENTS
THAT ARE COUNTIES IS BLUE IT
AND TRANSIENT AND DURING THE
TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN BY
COUNTY POINTED KIND COUNT 20%
OF EACH COUNTY HOMELESSNESS AND
CLAIM THEIR LAST RESIDENTS
WITHIN THE NEIGHBORING
JURISDICTION. WITH THE ONSET OF
HOMELESSNESS AND ONE COUNTY AND
THE MIGRATION ABOUT THEIR
LIVING BETWEEN THE TWO COUNTIES
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESSING AND
BREAK THE BARRIERS TO HOUSING
AND PROMOTING HEALTH AND WELL
BEING IS DIFFICULT AT BEST FOR
SOME OF UR REGION'S MOST
VULNERABLE CITIZENS. I CREATING
A JOINT HOMELESS MULTI
DISCIPLINARY PERSONAL TEAM WE
WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
SEAMLESS CASE MANAGEMENT AND
VACATION FOR THE END OF IT TOO
OTHERWISE RIGHT IN THE CLUE
AREA OF THE COUNTY'S. ONLY EVER
INTERACT WITH ENFORCEMENT. WITH
YOUR AUTHORIZATION AB ONE
TWENTY FOR IDENTIFICATION MEANT
AND SUPPORT OF BUT THAT WILL BE
ANYWHERE. EVEN PLAYED AN
INTERIM OR. REGARD THEIR OWN
CHILDREN LOOK. AND YOU. THE
COUNTIES HAVE COME ON OTHER
JOINT COUNTY INITIATIVE
INCLUDING THE BIKE BE HEALTH
NINETEEN TWO A BY COUNTY HOME
SERVICES PROGRAMS TO THE AND
EARLIER THIS YEAR UP I CAN
PUBLIC OFFICE. THE INTENTION OF
THE TWO CAN HAD THIS WE'VE BEEN
COLLABORATION AND THIS IS ONE
FURTHER TOWARDS COLLABORATIVELY
AND HOME. FOR AND SO ARE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NOW FOR OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT HERE.
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT.
TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
GOING OUT.
AND FOR
THOSE OF YOU ON THE PHONE
QUEUING UP TO OFFER YOUR
SUPPORT ON AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION. SEEING AND HEARING NO
ONE. LET'S IS THEREARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
FOR ANYBODY OPPOSED PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN FOR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. SEEING AND
HEARING NO OPPOSITION LET'S
BRING IT HERE TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MISTER MISTER GIBSON THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MADAM CHAIR I
UNDERSTAND THERE COULD BE
POSSIBLY- SOME PRIVACY ISSUES-
HAVE YOU- ADDRESS ANY PRIVACY
SO WE TRY THAT ONE MORE TIME
FOR. TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW MR GIPSON
TO CONTINUE HIS QUESTION AND
THEN WE WILL GO BACK TO CALL
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS ON THE
LINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MUCH MADAM CHAIR ON SAY
THERE COULD BE SOME PRIVACY
ISSUES HAVE YOU BEEN- A PRIZE
OF ANY PRIVACY ISSUES AND IF
SO- HAVE YOU TRIED TO ATTEMPT
TO ADDRESS THOSE PRIVACY ISSUES
THAT- COULD COME UP BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT MR SANTIAGO ALSO. DID
A DEAL THAT HAS SOME KIND OF
GENERATIONS AND AMENDMENTS-
JUST MAKING SURE THAT DOESN'T
HURT SOME THE ALREADY EXISTING
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE- THE
WORKING PROGRAMS LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SO- I'LL BE INTERESTED
TO HEAR YOUR RESPONSE THAT.
JUST GALLAGHER SURE SO. I
MYSELF- YOUR MANY ASPECTS HAVE
BEEN VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
PRIVACY- SO CERTAINLY THAT'S A
CONCERN OF MINE AS WELL- I
DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S ANY
PRIVACY CONCERNS- BY THE
PRESENT BILL. IT MATCHES- WHAT
LA COUNTY- LA COUNTIES PROGRAM
HAS DONE- AND SO WE'RE NOT
DOING ANYTHING DIFFERENTLY THAN
WHAT LA COUNTIES- PROGRAM.
UNDER OUR PROPOSED. BILL THERE
HAVE BEEN- ISN'T IN YOUR
ANALYSIS PRIVACY COMMITTEE HAS
RAISED SOME CONCERNS- YEAH BUT
THE AMENDMENTS THAT THEY WANT
WOULD ACTUALLY CHANGE MISTER
SANTIAGO'S BILL. AND MY BILL ON
THE ISSUE OF CONSENT- AND THAT
WOULD BE PROBLEMATIC I MEAN I
I'M NOT IN A PLACE WHERE I CAN
ACCEPT AMENDMENTS IS GONNA
CHANGE- A PROGRAM THAT'S
ALREADY IN PLACE IN LA COUNTY
AND LA COUNTY COULD PROBABLY
SPEAK MORE TO THOSE CONCERNS I
THINK THERE. ONE OF THE
ENTITIES ITS ON THE CALL- SO
MAYBE THEY COULD SPEAK MORE
SPECIFICALLY TO THAT BUT- YOU
KNOW I CAN'T ACCEPT AMENDMENTS
THAT THEY'RE PROPOSING THAT
WOULD CHANGE. WHAT THIS
COMMITTEE AND LEGISLATORS
ALREADY BETTER THAN APPROVED
LAST LAST YEAR WITH MR
SANTIAGO'S BILL. WE'RE JUST
KEEPING IT THE SAME AS WHAT HAS
ALREADY BEEN IN PLACE. PREVIEW
TO RESPONSE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER STONE. THANK YOU WELL
FOR CLARITY THAT THAT'S NOT
ENTIRELY TRUE WHAT THIS DOES.
IS THAT IT CREATES TWO
DIFFERENT CLASSES SO THAT THERE
IS AFFIRMATIVE CONSENT IF THERE
IS SOMEONE WHO IS AT RISK OF
BEING HOMELESS FOUR BEING
SERVED BY THESE MULTIPLE THE
MOTTO THIS FIRE TEAMS. BUT IF
SOMEONE IS ALREADY HOME WAS
THERE IS NO AFFIRMATIVE CONSENT
SO IT'S GOOD THAT'S THE
CHALLENGE HERE IS IT'S
CREATING. A DICHOTOMY AND SO
FOR SOMEONE WHO IS AS
SUPPORTIVE OF PRIVACY RIGHTS AS
I THOUGHT MISTER GALLAGHER HAD
BEEN ON I'M SURPRISED AT THAT
HE HASN'T TAKEN THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THAT
DISCREPANCY. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. WE
DO HAVE ONE ON THE PHONE LINES
HOMICIDE SHERRY'S ARION PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I PREFER GOING WITH
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENT. MISTER GALLAGHER YOU
MENTIONED THAT THE COUNTY OF
SALMON IT DOES COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES. WAS ON THE LINE.
SHOULD WE BE WAITING FOR THEM.
I BELIEVE THAT THEY MIGHT HAVE
BEEN. I HAD BEEN TOLD THAT THEY
MIGHT BE COMING ONLINE OKAY
THERE IS REALLY THEIR CONCERN
AS WELL THAT WE DON'T TAKE THAT
ELEMENT BECAUSE IT WOULD SET A
PRECEDENT AND CHANGE THEIR BILL
IT WOULD ACTUALLY CHANGE THEIR
PROGRAM. WELL AND ME AS I'VE
STATED THERE REALLY. IS NOT I
MEAN THERE IS NO THERE IS NO
HOMELESS ADVOCACY PROGRAM HAS
RAISE THIS AS A CONCERN THERE
HAS BEEN NO OPPOSITION STATED
THIS IT IT KEEPS IT THE SAME AS
LA COUNTIES PROGRAM THAT AGAIN
HAS ALREADY BEEN APPROVED BY
THIS LEGISLATURE- PREVIOUSLY SO
I DON'T SEE THE CONCERN THAT IS
BEING. THAT IS BEING REYES I
JUST I DON'T AGREE WITH THAT
AND AGAIN AT FIVE TAKE THAT
AMENDMENT LA COUNTY WOULD BE
OPPOSED TO THIS. TO THIS
PROGRAM BECAUSE IT. WOULD
CREATE. IT WOULD SET THAT IN IN
PLACE FOR THEM AS WELL AND
WE'RE JUST SAYING HEY WHAT'S
BEEN ALLOWED HERE LET'S ALLOWED
FOR YUBA AND SUTTER COUNTY AS
WELL WHO ARE WORKING. IN THESE
MD MD TEAS WHO WANT TO WORK IN
THESE ENTITIES AS WELL. IT IS
THE AS WAS NOTED AT THE
BEGINNING. WE ARE NOT DOING
DON'T DOUBLE REFERRALS HERE IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND THAT IS WHY
THE PRIVACY COMMITTEE DID- WAY
AND THE COMMENTS ARE NOTED-
THEIR CONCERNS REGARDING
PRIVACY. ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. SAYING NONE PLEASE
TAKE THE WORLD. SO THE MOTION
WAS TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR. RIGHT YES HI RES I
MATHIS HI MATHIS HI ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI FLORA. FLORA HI
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN HI GIPSON
GIPSON HI MAIENSCHEIN. STONE
STONE HI THE CURRENT VOTED
SEVEN TO ZERO. THANK YOU THAT
MEASURE WILL BE RECORD WOULD BE
LEFT OPEN FOR ABSENT NUMBER.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
GALLAGHER. ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
TWO THREE SEVEN SEVEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TRUE. MORNING
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR GOOD MORNING
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN WILL REDUCE THE
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS FOR
RESIDENTIAL OF ADULT
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS AIR APPS. S.
ALONG WITH RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY ARE
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS
BOARDING CARE STAY OFFER
RESIDENTIAL LIVING FOR
INDIVIDUALS NO LONGER ABLE TO
LIVE INDEPENDENTLY. WHILE
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES
SERVE SENIORS AYRES'S SERVE
MANY OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS INCLUDING THOSE WITH
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESSES OR
OTHER CHRONIC CONDITIONS. IN
RECENT YEARS THESE FACILITIES
HAVE BEEN CLOSING AT AN
ALARMING RATE. THIS TREND IS
HIT AIR OF RESIDENTS PERIOD
HARD SINCE THEY'RE CLOSE
REQUIREMENTS ARE LESS
PROTECTIVE THAN THOSE FOR
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES
PUTTING RESIDENTS AT GREATER
RISK FOR HOMELESSNESS. THIS
BILL WOULD ADDRESS THE
SITUATION BY EXPANDING THE
ERROR OF CLOSURE REQUIREMENTS
TO BE MORE SIMILAR TO THOSE FOR
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY. AND GIVING
GOVERNMENT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TOOLS TO ENSURE THAT THESE
FACILITIES STAY OPEN. AIR IF
OPERATORS WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE SIX MONTHS NOTICE TO
RESIDENTS PRIOR TO CLOSURE.
GIVE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE
FIRST OPPORTUNITY TO PURCHASE A
FACILITY WITHIN TWO MONTHS AT
FAIR MARKET VALUE. PROVIDE A
RELOCATION PLAN FOR ALL
RESIDENTS SUBMIT A CLOSURE PLAN
TO THE STATE. AND ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FLEXIBILITY IN
USING MENTAL HEALTH AND
HOMELESS PREVENTION FUNDS
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE. BEFORE
COVER NINETEEN THIS BILL WAS
IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS HER
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS WITH THE
PANDEMIC IT'S CRITICAL TO
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC HEALTH OF
BOTH AIR F. RESIDENTS AND THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY. AND WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO TURN IT OVER
TO OUR WITNESSES. PRETTY GOOD
ONLINE KELLY YOUR MODEM. GOOD
MORNING SHERIDAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS KELLY
CARE MODEL AND THE SPECIAL
PROJECT MANAGER ACCOUNTS AT THE
PARK THE PUBLIC HEALTH. READ IN
THE TO THE IN CANYON COUNTY
JUST GO I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR HEARING THIS BILL TODAY
UNDER UNPRECEDENTED
CIRCUMSTANCE AND I WANT TO MAKE
A FAMILY MEMBER DAVID CHIU FOR
HIS SUPPORT LEADERSHIP IN
CALLING ATTENTION TO THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SUPPORTING KEPT MONEY
FOR ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THREE
SEVEN SEVEN. AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN REDUCES THE RISK
OF HOMELESSNESS FOR VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS OF RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITY BY CREATING STRONGER
CLOSER REQUIREMENTS FOR ADULT
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY. I
DON'T RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES
ERA IN RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY YET
HE SPOKE CALMLY REFER TO FORTY
CARE HOMES PLAN INTEGRAL ROLE
HOUSING SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS. THE
FACILITIES OFFER SUPPORT OF
RESIDENTIAL LIVING FOR AND IT
WILL NOT CURRENTLY ABLE EIGHT
ON THEIR HOME SHERMAN CISCO
LIKE MANY OTHER COUNTIES ACROSS
THE STATE EXPERIENCING
UNPRECEDENTED LOST THE
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES.
AND IT'S LOCKED IS INCREASING
EVERY YEAR BETWEEN TWENTY
TWELVE AND TWENTY NINETEEN
CHARACTERS THE LOS FORTY THREE
FACILITIES. FOR TWO HUNDRED
FORTY THREE BAD A 30% DECLINE
IN THE PHILIPPINES AND A 9%
DECLINE IN BED. IT IS PLACE
CLIENTS FROM THESE RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITIES ARE OFTEN
DEPENDENT ADULT YEARS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE HISTORY THEY NEED A
STRUCTURED SUPPORTIVE
ENVIRONMENT. MANY HAVE SUFFERED
FROM TRAUMATIC EVENTS AND ALSO
HOW COMPLEX MEDICAL CONDITIONS
HAVE EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS
AND ARE AN ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR
BASIC NEEDS LIKE FOOD AND
SHELTER. A LOT CURRENTLY
PROVIDE THREE LOCATION RIGHT TO
PROTECTIONS FOR RESIDENTS
DISPLACED FROM ARTS YET HE AND
I ARE A FEW TO PHILLY CLOSURE
HOWEVER THE RIGHT YOU'RE
DIFFERENT FOR EACH TYPE OF
FACILITY WITH RTS EACH HAVE A
GREATER LEVEL FOR PROTECTION.
LONGER AGAIN NOTED THING
REQUIRED RETURNING EVALUATION
CLOSURE PLANNING AIR AFTER
INCREASINGLY SERVING GREATER
NUMBERS OF HONORABLE RESIDENTS
LIKE THOSE DESCRIBED EARLIER
BECAUSE THEY'RE THEY'RE
VULNERABILITY THE CURRENT
HOUSING CRISIS ERA PRESIDENT
ARE SPECIALLY AT RISK OF
BECOMING HOMELESS ON THE
FACILITY CLOSES. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO THREE SEVEN SEVEN WOULD
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BY ALIGNING.
THEIR OF CLOSURE REQUIREMENT TO
THOSE OF ARTS YET THE ENSURING
THAT. THE ERA PRESIDENT ARE
PROVIDED SIMILAR PROTECTIONS
THAT ARE HIPPIE RESIDENTS HAVE
ONE OF THE FILL THE CLOSES. THE
BILL ALSO ADDRESSES. THE TIME
CENTER PROBLEM RELATED TO COKE
AT NINETEEN. AND COULD PROVIDE
RESOURCE ANSWER THAT ASSIST
FUTURE MY HERE TO. RISK AND-
YOU'RE COVERED NINETEEN WE HAVE
A LOT THAT WE TAKE. MEASURE TO
HELP. MOST VULNERABLE. BY
IMPROVING ARAB. IN HELLO WILL
BE BETTER ABLE TO REDUCE RISK
OF HOME. PROJECT SOME OF THE
STATE MOST LONGER COMMUNITIES.
REDUCE THE RISK OF FUTURE
HEALTH EMERGENCY. I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDER. THANK YOU NECK
WITNESS STEVE THE SHOP. STEVE
THIS COUGH. THE SHELF. YOUR
PHONE PLEASE PRESS STAR SIX IF
YOUR PHONE IS MUTED. STEVE FISH
OFF IF YOU ARE ON THE LINE WE
CANNOT HEAR YOU PLEASE PRESS
STAR SIX. SO WE CAN HEAR YOU.
CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW WE CAN HEAR
YOU. AT ONE. THIRTY BUT MHM
CHAIR I AM STEVE THEY SHOP FOR
MANY YEARS I WAS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE LOS THOUGH SHE
STILL MANY COUNTY IT WAS IN
THAT JOB I GOT TO KNOW ABOUT-
FORTY CARES MANY OF THE PEOPLE
WE SERVE WILL RESIDENTS WORKING
HERE. AND OFTEN FAMILY CARE
GIVERS THE PEOPLE WAS THAT
IMPORTANT. I'M TALKING ABOUT A
ARE ABSENT THIS POINT. I WAS
VERY PLEASED USUAL YEAR AND
SINCE THEN I'VE BEEN ACTIVE IN
THE EAST BAY SUPPORTER HAS A
COLLABORATIVE. LEVERAGES
MISSION IS TO INCREASE THE
SUPPLY. PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING FOR PEOPLE WITH SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS ONE FORM OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
AND IT WAS NOTED EARLIER THE
SUPPLY WOULDN'T CARE JUSTIN
SHRINKING A LOT OVER TIME.
LEADERS FOR THAT INCLUDES SUCH
THINGS OF THE INNING INADEQUATE
REIMBURSEMENT PROVIDING
SERVICES OPERATORS GETTING
OLDER GOING RETIRE. AND
PROBABLY A LOT THE TRIP IT
INCREASE IN VALUE CALLED. AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
ESTABLISHES SOME IMPORTANT
MANDATE THAT WILL MAKE LIFE
BETTER WHO RESIDENTS TO BOARD
HOMES. NOW WITH AN OPERATOR
PLANS TO CLOSE THERE'S VERY
LITTLE OF THIS REQUIREMENT
BEYOND THAT GIVEN TO THE PART
OF THE SOCIAL SERVICES. AN
EXAMPLE HOW HOW THAT CAN WORK
OUT WITH HOME BECAUSE IN
BERKELEY A FEW YEARS AGO.
RESIDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
HEARD RUMORS THAT THE STUDY WAS
PLAN TO CLOSE. THE FINALLY
CONFRONTED THE OPERATORS SAID
THAT WAS THE CASE. IN THIS CASE
THERE WAS NO REQUIREMENT- THAT
THEY SHE FIND A DATA FILE THE
POTENTIAL HOUSING OR MAKE ANY
KIND OF RELOCATION PLAN TO SHE
DIDN'T. WHAT THIS RESULTED IN
WAS A MAN FOR THE- AND FAMILIES
TRYING TO FIND OTHERHOUSING.
FOR THEMSELVES. AT THAT POINT
THERE WAS NO NOTICE REQUIREMENT
THAT WOULD GIVE THIS CITY OF
BERKLEY THE COUNTY LEVEL MEDIA.
TIME TO DECIDE TO TRY TO
PURCHASE THIS IS SO THEY- AND
IN THIS CASE A PRIVATE PARTY
SHOULD BUT- RELATIVELY QUICKLY.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
AND IT. ESTABLISHES IMPORTANT
NOTICE REQUIREMENTS AS WELL
HAVE BEEN REFERRED TO BEFORE.
IN ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT I
THINK IN ADDITION TO THE
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS. IS THE
MANDATE THE OPERATOR TO ASSIST
RESIDENTS NEED TO THE
DEMOCRATIC SUITABLE CREW SO
THESE. WITHIN SIXTY MILES. SO
THIS THESE ARE VERY IMPORTANT
CHANGES THAT WILL BE VERY VERY
HELPFUL TO PEOPLE. IN WORKING
CARE THAN THEIR FAMILY CARE
GIVERS AND- I WANT TO STRONGLY
SUPPORTED. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ON THE LINE. ON THE
PHONE LINES TO SUPPORT SHOW
YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
MOMENT WE ARE ONE KILLING UP
WILL GO TO THE LINE OF SIGHT
SHERRY'S ARION PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE STORIES ARE IN WITH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH RECORD
WITH THE STATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE. ANY ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. BOB POSITION AT
THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. ONE MOMENT THERE'S A
COUPLE PARK QUEUING UP AND
WE'LL GO TO REBEKAH GONZALEZ'S
WINE. RESIDENT ALL YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ABER BECKY GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THERE WAS SURPRISE ME
TO HEAR THE RESULT NOW POSITION.
WHAT SURPRISED ME TO. AND THERE
IS ONE MORE WITH THE OPERATOR
ONE MOMENT. AND THEY'RE NOT
RESPONDING TO THE OPERATOR I'M
SORRY. I THANK YOU. ANY
OPPOSITION WE HEARD THE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. CLOSE MISTER TO
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
WANNA JUST THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR THE WORK THAT'S BEEN
DONE AND- TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS LEGISLATION REALLY
ADDRESSES THE ISSUE- THIS IS
NOT JUST BEEN AN ISSUE IN IN MY
AREA AND THE BAY AREA BUT I'LL
JUST MENTION FOR SOME THE LA
MEMBERS JUST THIS PAST YEAR.
THERE WERE TWO HUNDRED BEDS
THAT WERE CLOSE TO THESE TYPES
OF FACILITIES AND THIS IS WHY.
ALL OVER JURISDICTIONS NEED A
LONGER HEADS UP WHEN A- IT ONE
OF THESE FACILITIES MAY CLOSE
SO THAT WE CAN FIGURE OUT WHAT
TO DO SO- WITH THAT AGAIN
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU PLEASE TAKE THE
ROLE. WE HAVE A MOTION. THE
MOTION BY MISTER STONE SECOND
BY MISTER ARAMBULA DR ARAMBULA.
THE MOTION IS THE PAST TO
APPROPRIATIONS RADIUS I REYES
HI MY THIS. MATT IS NOT VOTING
OR- ARAMBULA EIGHT I. FLORA NOT
VOTING FREE FREEMEN I HI GIPSON
HI MANGE. STONE STONE I. AND
THE CURRENT VOTE FIVE ZERO
THANK YOU COUNTY WILL LEAVE THE
RECORD OPEN FOR APPS MEMBERS
THANK YOU. NEXT THE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
SEVEN MISTER GRAYSON. THE. WELL
THANK YOU. AND I WILL GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND- I AM
TO PRESENT AB TWO THREE EIGHTY
WHICH I AN IN HOME SO SERVICES
AND NO REASSESSED TO BE
PERFORMED TELEPHONICALLY
PROVIDED THAT CLIENTS MEET
CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS AND IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE ELIGIBILITY
IHS A SERVICES A CLIENT MUST BE
RE ASSESSED EVERY TWELVE MONTHS
SO NO IN PERSON ASSESSMENTS
ALSO- THEY POSE A WORKLOAD
ISSUE- THAT CURRENTLY EXIST BUT
ALSO AS WE KNOW THE TIMES THAT
WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW- GIVEN THE
INCREASING DEMAND FOR AYE HSS
AND WITH CURRENT SITUATION
REVOLVING ON COVERT NINETEEN.
THE INTRODUCTION OF TELEPHONIC
ASSESSMENTS WILL BE ABLE TO
STREAMLINE THE RE ASSESSMENTS
AND ENSURE EFFICIENT ACCESS TO
SERVICES WHILE PROTECTING
VULNERABLE AYE HSS CLIENTS AN
ESSENTIAL COUNTY SOCIAL WORKERS
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR ME TO
MENTION THAT THERE ARE ACTUALLY
FOUR PROGRAMS AND THIS BILL
ADDRESSES TWO OF THOSE ARE
TELEPHONIC ASIDE A
REASSESSMENTS- IT IS. THOSE TWO
PROGRAMS COVER APPROXIMATELY
LITTLE OVER 50% OF THOSE THAT
ARE INVOLVED WE ARE IN
CONVERSATIONS AND HAVE HAD
CONVERSATIONS AS WELL AS YOU
KNOW THE CHALLENGE WITH TIMING
WE ARE- WE CONTINUE TO BE OPEN
FOR DISCUSSION AND- TAKING-
HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS TURN
INTO WHATEVER AMENDMENTS TO BE
ABLE TO ACCEPT A BROADER RANGE
OF PEOPLE IF THAT WAS THE IF
THAT'S TO WORK OUT SO HAVING
SAID THAT I DO KNOW THAT I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A WITNESS. TREE
SEE MORE. YES THEY SIMMERING.
YEAH MADAM AND THEN ARE YOU
ABLE TO HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT- MY
NAME IS TRACY MURRAY I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF EIGHTEEN AND ADULTS
SEVICES FOR CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR PROVIDING THIS OPPORTUNITY
FOR ME TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT.
OF AB TWO THREE EIGHT SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW FOR CALIFORNIA
GRIFFITH WAS PRETTY IN HOME
SUPPORT FOR WITH THAT ALSO
KNOWN AS I A FACT PROGRAM. I
HATE HELP THE OVER SIXTY.
DISABLE PARKING IN THE GOOD PAY
THIRTY. PROVIDE TO THEM SO THEY
THEY CAN SAFELY IN THEIR OWN
HOME. I TOOK THAT IS THE-
GROWING SO SERVICE PROGRAMS
MANY CAL. IN COUNTRY COSTA
COUNTY. CALIFORNIANS ADULT POP
IS GROWING- RAPIDLY BY CHOOSE.
THOUSAND AND- ONLY ONE OUT OF
FIVE. CALIFORNIANS WILL BE OVER
THE AGE OF SIX FIVE. EVEN THE
MAN IN FACT EVERY FOR THIS
COUNTY THE OFFICIAL RESPONSE OF.
AND HIS SO ALTERNATIVE TO MEET.
IN HOME NEED. BECAUSE NINETEEN.
AND STATE SHELTERED PLACE ORDER
HI THE NEED FOR ALTERNATE CAL.
VIDEO AND MEANS YOU. WITH A
VULNERABLE CLIENTS POPULATE.
WHO WHICH TO REMAIN WARRANTY AT
HOME. IN RESPONSE AND WITH THE-
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL FOR OF.
COUNTY SOCIAL WORK ARE NOW
CAMPER. IT WILL DO THAT HELLO
RESET. FOR I THAT THREE FIFTY A-
TELEPHONIC RESET OR I'M SORRY
FAST TRACKING GROUND IN PRO.
INCLUDING WORKS MEDICARE AND
HEALTH. HELLO FUNDED A- FOR AN
ADDITIONAL TWO UNVEIL TO SO
WORKER. AND I HAVE RESEARCH.
PROVIDING FLEX. CONVENIENCE
CONSUMER. AND EFFICIENTLY
COUNTY. IN THE CURRENT HOPE IT
NINETEEN. MANY AYE HSS IF YOU
WORK HAVE EXPRESS A PRIEST. FOR
ABILITY TO PURCHASE IN YOUR-
MEANT OVER THE PHONE. PASSAGE
OF THIS BILL WOULD PRINT. I
HAVE A THREE FIFTY. WITH WOULD
HAVE THEY ARE AND WOULD PREFER
BOX FILE ANY TO OPT. FOR AN
INCREASE TO READ. EVEN AFTER
TELEPHONE AFFECT MEANT WAS
OFFERED. IN SUMMARY COUNTY
CURRENT CAMP ALLOWED TO CONDUCT
TELEPHONE. FOR AYE AGE OF RESET.
AND WE RECKON CAUGHT OF THESE
OPTIONS AT CONTAINED IN A TWO
THREE EIGHT SEVEN. THIS TIME OF
FIFTY EMPATH THE CURRENT AND ON
THE. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES HELLO
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU HAPPEN OF
WILLIAM THANK YOU THIS KEVIN
OPEN COALITION CALIFORNIA WILL
PROVIDE CERTAIN RESERVATIONS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL IT
SHOWS ABOUT TIME WE STARTED
SHOULD TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND THE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OUT.
YES THIS IS JESSICA BARBARA
WHAT YOU'RE NOT ALONE POVERTY
AND WE SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. AN EIGHTY TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY SEVEN. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE LET'S BRING IT TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MISTER MATHIS. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MISTER GRACE
AND I. DO APPRECIATE- YOU
WORKING WITH ALL THE PARTIES ON
THIS- IT IS DEFINITELY TIME WE
MOVE INTO THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY I KNOW- A LOT OF US
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
FOR YEARS- I THINK IT'S TRAGIC
AND UNFORTUNATE IT'S TAKEN-
PANDEMIC TO GET US TO MOVE
FORWARD AS A STATE. BUT I'M
GLAD TO SEE THESE MEASURES
GOING FORWARD IN. MY SUPPORT ON
THIS AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'RE DOING HERE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SAYING HEARING NONE
MR GRAYSON WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAVAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WITH
MOTION AND A SECOND LET'S TAKE
FROM. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
RADIUS HI RES HI MATT THIS.
MATHIS HI ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI
FLORA. FLORA HI FRIEDMAN.
FREEMAN HI GIPSON. GIPSON HI
MAIENSCHEIN. STONE STONE HI THE
CURRENT POTUS SEVEN ZERO THANK
YOU WILL LEAVE THE RECORD OPEN
FOR ABSENT MMBERS. MAKING THE
MOST BURKE. IS MR GONE HER WAY.
OTHERWISE WE WILL TAKE CALDERON
OUT OF ORDER.
THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR WE ARE. NOW GOING TO MOVE
TO OUR ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX CALDERON
AND OUR TERROR IS GOING TO BE
PRESENTING. SECOND THANK YOU-
MEMBERS AND CHAIR PRESENTING
THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON. FOR ANYONE
THAT HAS AD TO FACE A
DIFFICULT DECISION TO PLACE A
SENIOR LOVED ONE AND INSISTED
LIVING FACILITY YOU KNOW HOW
DIFFICULT IT CAN BE TO FIND THE
RIGHT PLACE. A SIMPLE A SIMPLE
GOOGLE SEARCH FOR RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITY FOR THE ELDERLY
OR R. C. F. E. FOR SHORT IN
YOUR AREA CAN REVEAL A DOZEN
FACILITIES WITHIN A TWENTY MILE
RADIUS. THIS IS WHERE REFERRAL
SOURCES BECOME SO VITAL AS THEY
UTILIZE KEY INFORMATION ABOUT
OF SENIORS HEALTH AND NEEDS TO
PROVIDE REFERRALS TO THE MOST
APPROPRIATE. RC A FEES IN YOUR
AREA. AND BECAUSE REFERRAL
SOURCES GET PAID A FEE FOR RC A
FEES WHEN THEY GET A NEW
CLIENTS THE REFERRAL SOURCES.
HELP IN FINDING A FACILITY
COMES AT NO COST TO THE SENIORS
AND THEIR FAMILY. WHILE THE
REFERRAL SOURCES HAVE BEEN
CONDUCTING BUSINESS FOR DECADES
CURRENT LAW LACKS SUFFICIENT
REGULATIONS AND PROVIDES A
MINIMAL CONSUMER PROTECTIONS.
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX
ADDRESSES THESE CONCERNS. AND
WITH ME- TO GIVE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT IS CLIFF BURKE FROM
PLACE FOR MOM AND MONICA MILLER
FROM CONSUMER ADVOCATES FOR OUR
SEE IF YOU PERFORM. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FIRST WITNESS
PLEASE MISTER BURKE. ARE THERE
WITNESSES ON THIS BILL THIS IS
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX. AS
MILLER MISTER BURKE MONICA
MILLER'S ON ALL RIGHT IS
ANOTHER. I'M HAPPY KILL YEAH OF
COURSE SO MONICA MILLER
PARTNERSHIP CONSUMER ADVOCATE
RCMP WEB FORMS ON AND WE HAVE
WORKED COLLABORATIVE LEAD WITH
ABOUT A PLACE FOR MOM AND TURN
DOT COM FOR THE LAST COUPLE
NINE IF YOU RECALL THE VIEW
THAT IT THAT ON. I'M COMMITTEE
FOR AWHILE DISEASE ISSUE THAT
ARE WRITING COURSE. OUT OF THE
FLAT YEARS. AND WEBER TO THE
FIRST TIME THAT THE INDUSTRY
CONSUMER HAVE COME TOGETHER. WE
THAT THIS IS JUST VERY
FRAMEWORK. TO WHAT SOMETHING
THAT HELPS. UNDER WHEN THEY ARE
LOOKING FOR A- POLITICAL A LOT
ONE ARE I CAN REMEMBER ON AND-
SO MUCH IN THE- AT. NOBODY
RIGHT NOW THE BILL HAS ZERO.
GPS OUR WENT OUT. SO ON AND SO
WE PUT. THAT TO THE DON'T MAKE
SENSE. HELLO I HOLD ON MR VERY.
SO MANY TESTIFY THANK YOU. GO
AHEAD MS MILLER I JUST THAT
THAT THANK YOU I CAN TO GET
THOSE AT THE VERY TOP OF
PREMARKET WITH PUTTING IN PLACE
I WE CAN I TELL HAPPY ANY. AND
WITH BURKE I TRIED AND ALSO HAD
PATRICK SHE ON IN THE HILL.
QUESTION TO REPRESENT. COMMON
GET ALL HAVE. SAYS THAT ON HIS
TECHNICAL. GOT AT EVEN THE UP
IN THE TWENTY. BUT I WILL DEFER
TO CLICK THAT POINT AND HAVE
UNDER THE- THANK YOU MISTER
BURKE. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES CAN. A THANK YOU VERY MUCH
A PERSON TINK THE CHAIR OF
BOTH WERE HERE OUR BILL THE
SCHOOL REAL WERE KNOWING HOW TO
THE IS RIGHT A WE DO WANT TO
SOME CAL FOR OFF. THE BILL ALSO
WANT TO SAY MONICA MIL AND HER
CLIENT KERR WORKERS ANY CAN
COMING TO WITH. TO TRY TO FOR
THE FIRST TIME IT- GET ENACTED
A SET OF- DISCLOSURES AND
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS- SEEKING A REFERRAL
TO A WERE RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITY- ON BEHALF OF A PLACE
FOR MOM. I WILL TELL YOU THIS
BILL AS A RESULT OF OVER SIX
MONTHS OF NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN
INDUSTRY. CART ESTABLISH A TRAY.
PROCESS FOR CONSUMERS- A PLACE
FOR MOM IT IS COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING FAMILY MEMBERS
CRITICAL ASSISTANCE THEY NEED
IN FINDING THE RIGHT ASSISTED
LIVING FACILITY FOR THEIR LOVE
ONE. OFTEN IN A TIME OF CRISIS
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX-
PROVIDES BOTH. THE SERIES OF
NOTICES FOR THE CONSUMER OR
THEIR FAMILY. AS WELL AS OTHER
CONSUMER PROTECTION SUCH AS
BACKGROUND CHECKS ON REFERRAL
AGENCY STAFF. WHOEVER DIRECT
CONTACT WITH SENIORS REQUIRES
LIABILITY INSURANCE LIMITS ANY
BACK CHANNEL REMUNERATION TO
REFERRAL AGENCY REQUIRES A
REFERRAL AGENCIES CONTAINING
DISPLAY PRIVACY POLICY INTERNET
WEBSITE. AND PREVENTS CONFLICTS
OF INTEREST IN REFERRAL-
NUMEROUS ATTEMPTS HAVE BEEN
MADE TO ENACT LEGISLATION IN
THE AREA OVER THE LAST SIX
YEARS- POST EITHER GOT KILLED
IN ASSEMBLY PURPOSE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE OR-
WELL BEING YOUR FOR THE
GOVERNOR. OUR APPROACH HERE WAS
IN. HERE'S IT DOES NOT INCLUDE
THAT EVERY PARTY TO THE
NEGOTIATIONS WANTED BUT OUR
UNDERLYING PRINCIPLE WAS TO
REACH CONSENSUS AS TO WHAT
WOULD BE IN THE BILL AND NOT
INCLUDE ANYTHING THAT ANYONE
OBJECTED TO- THEREFORE I WOULD
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
MEASURE I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT. PIECE OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION THAT WE CAN GET DONE
THIS YEAR- IN THIS LEGISLATIVE
SESSION THANK YOU. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
SO NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
OTHERS IN SUPPORT IF YOU COULD
JUST. INDICATE YOUR SUPPORT
YOUR NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION.
SIR ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO. REGISTER SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL. THIS IS AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY SIX BY MISTER CALDERON.
ALL RIGHT HEARING NONE IS THERE
OPPOSITION. THREE ONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO REGISTER OPPOSITION TO
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX. ALL
RIGHT HEARING NONE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE BIZRATE'S
ON BEHALF OF MISTER CALDERON
MAKES LEVEL YES RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS RADIUS HI RES HI
MATT THIS MATHIS HI ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI FLORA FLORA HI
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I'D GIFTS AND
GIFTS AND I MAIENSCHEIN. STONE
HI STONE HI THE CURRENT VOTER
SEVEN ZERO. THANK YOU AND IS
THE CHAIR COMES BACK UP MS
BURKE THE NUMBER OF TIED NUMBER
SIX AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY SEVEN.
THE SECOND. DEFINITELY NOT
LOOKING TO TALK MYSELF OUT OF
ANYTHING ESPECIALLY WITH THIS
MASK ON SO I APPRECIATE HER
ROLE IN THE MOTION AND THE
SECOND I ALSO MY DAUGHTER'S
WATCHING AND SHE SUPER NERVOUS
ABOUT ME BEING HEARING
COMMITTEE TODAY SO HONEY I HAVE
MY MASK ON A LOVE YOU. GOOD AND
I'LL JUST BE SUPER BRIEF- THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY FIFTH FIVE
SIXTY SEVEN IN THE LAST TWO
MONTHS WE ALL KNOW THAT THERE'S
BEEN BACK A DECADE OF. THAT WE
ARE HITTING I'M A WHOLE NEW
MASSIVE INCREASE IN
APPLICATIONS FOR STATES VERY
SOCIAL SAFETY NET PROGRAMS OF
NEARLY THREE POINT FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. APPLYING FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE ALONE.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE VITAL EVEN
IN THE BEST OF TIMES AND THEY
KEEP NEARLY TWO POINT EIGHT
MILLION CALIFORNIANS OUT OF
POVERTY. IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED SB TEN
FORTY ONE A BUDGET TRAILER BILL
TO AMEND CAL WORKS IN ANSWER TO
TWENTY MONTHS. IT WITHIN THE
TOTAL FORTY EIGHT MONTH OF THE
LIFETIME OF EIGHT PERMITTING.
THE TWENTY MONTH CLOCK PLAY
FROM UNPLUG MAKES ELIGIBLE
VARIETY FLEXIBLE WELFARE TO
WORK ACTIVITIES IN WHICH- A CAL
WORKS CIENT CAN PARTICIPATE.
THESE INCLUDE THINGS LIKE JOB
TRAINING SKILLS ADULT EDUCATION
AND EARNING A D. G. E. D.
HOWEVER THAT TWENTY FOUR MONTH
OF ENGAGING THESE ACTS OF THE
AND- CLIENTS ORG ARE REQUIRED
TO ENGAGE IN ESSENTIAL THREE
ACTIVITIES EMPLOYMENT. WHETHER
AND SUBSIDIZE OR SUBSIDIZE
COMMUNITY SERVICE OR WORK STUDY
AB TWENTY FIVE SIX SEVEN WOULD
STANDARDIZE ACTIVITIES ACROSS
THE TWO TIME CLOCKS BY MAKING
ELIGIBLE TO FLEXIBLE THIRD WORK
ACTIVE. THESE FOR THE ENTIRE
DURATION OF A CLIENT'S TIME ON
THE AID. ADDITIONALLY AB TWENTY
FIVE SIX SEVEN EXTEND THE TOTAL
LIFETIME EIGHT TO SIXTY MONTHS.
SUCH THE CLIENTS WOULD BE ABLE
TO PARTAKE IN SIXTY MONTHS OF
FLEXIBLE WELFARE TO WORK
pTHE BARRIERS TO THEIR
EMPLOYMENT WITHOUT ITS REQUEST
AND I BOTH. THANK YOU WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. JESSICA BARCELONA.
HELLO BARBARA WITH THE WEAPONS
AND I'M- POVERTY AS YOU HEARD.
AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY SEVEN
EXTENSIVE HANCOCK BUT BUILT
FROM FORTY EIGHT FIFTY NINE AND
ELIMINATE THE TWENTY FOUR MONTH
TIME AT TEN O'CLOCK
REQUIREMENTS OF LAMB. IT ALSO
ALLOWS YOU TO GET THE
PARTICIPATE IN WORK ACTIVITY.
FOR THE ENTIRETY UNDER FIFTEEN
MONTHS. HI I'M LET ONLY IN
ADULT. FOR A PARENT TO THE
AIRPORT WELL DONE. AND WHAT
PARTICIPATE IN CAMP IN THE
POWER COOPER WORK FOR. I CAN I
DON'T NOT FORGET OR TWO THAT
NOT TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM THEY'RE ALREADY NOT
RECEIVING A- SO THE TIME WHEN I
MEASURE TO ON ALL. HARM PEOPLE
QUIRK. THEIR HARDEST TO GET OUT
OF POVERTY. THE SECOND TIME A
LITTLE OVER A DECADE OUR
ECONOMY HAS GONE IN TO A DEEP
RECESSION. AND MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE HAVE LOST
THEIR JOBS. MANY OF THEM ARE
RETURNING. AFTER THAT AGAIN TO
THE CALICO GRAHAM SUMMER
TENTATIVE AROUND FOR THE FIRST
TIME EVER. THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN THE PROGRAM RIGHT NOW- ARE
HAVE ALREADY BEEN HARD AT WORK
STRUGGLING TO OVERCOME
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT OR SECURE ESSENTIAL
WORK TRAINING. AND A NOW FADED
THE END OF THE TIME ON THAT.
WELL THAT SAME PATH THAT
THEY'VE BEEN PURSUING COULD
ACHIEVE ECONOMIC SELF
SUFFICIENCY HAVE BECOME MORE
DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE WITH A
HOME ORDER. AND SOCIAL
DISTANCING. DOES THAT WORK ON
EIGHT IN THE PAST DECADE BUT
HAS SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITIONED
OFFICER THANK. AND NOW RETURN
OF COURSE TO RETURN TO THE
PROGRAM. WITH OLDER CHILDREN
ARE- PERHAPS IN A SITUATION OF
FACING AT AND A MONTH ON AID
DURING- TIME LIMIT. BOTH IN THE
LAST RECESSION AND AFTER
SESSION DURING TIMES WHEN
NOBODY CAN FIND WORK. ACTUALLY
TO FOR THE POPULATION OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE SPOKE BY THE POWER FOR
THEM WHO ARE PREDOMINANTLY
SINGLE MOTHERS AND WOMEN OF
COLOR. AND THAT SAME WORKERS
THAT. ARE UNABLE TO FIND A
HOMEWORK. I THE POLICY NOT A
WEAPONS AND ON ON POVERTY HAVE
LONG BELIEVED THAT KIND ONE
THAT ON ANY BASICALLY PROGRAM
ARE ARBITRARY AND ARE BORN OUT
OF A STEREOTYPE OF WOMEN OF
COLOR PARTICULARLY AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND LATINO WOMEN. THAT
WITHOUT A TIME LIMIT THEY WOULD
SOMEHOW BE LACK AND- KILEY
POVERTY. I AN TELL YOU THAT
POVERTY AND THE HARM IN A
BIGGER VIçT BRING IS
MOTIVATED ENOUGH FOR ANYONE.
THAT DELIVERY AND THAT TO WORK.
HARD TO LEAVE. NOT IT THAT
PERSON MORE NOT LAPTOP YOU CAN
ASK YOUR WRAP UP YOUR CALL
WHAT'S PLEASE. AT THE EIGHT
NINE AND TEN FINALLY I WOULD WE
WERE JUST ADD THAT THERE'S YOU
KNOW CHARACTER EVIDENCE BUT AND
THEN THE WORK TRUCK THE CALL OF.
AVAILABLE COME BACK. THEY'RE
NOT I THANK THE RESEARCH THE OP
THAT THAT HELP PEOPLE WITH WHAT
TO WORK OUT BECAUSE THIS OUT OF
A- MORE QUICKLY. AND THE AND WE
ARE ACT. THAT CALIFORNIA JOIN
DAMAGE OF OTHERS. THAT USE THAT
OF NOT. A FEW MONTHS A- AS AT
THE TIME AND IN THE- AND- THAT
YOU NEED TO TELL AN ACT. AB
TWENTY IF. WE ARE I DON'T THINK
YOU. THANK YOU. FRANK MAKE. THE
MADAM CHAIR MAC EXACT DIRECTOR
OF THE COUNTY FOR YOUR OF.
WHICH ALSO STRONGLY AND OF THIS
MEASURE WE SUPPORT THE MEASURE
BECAUSE THE TIME LIMIT CHANGES
THAT WERE DESCRIBED BY THE
AUTHOR. WE'RE BASED ON
INVALIDATED INVOLVED WITH
PENSIONS. THAT TIME LIMITS ARE
NEEDED TO BE AN INCENTIVE FOR
PEOPLE TO PUSH THEM. TO TAKE
THEIR JOURNEY FROM- RECEIVED AS
CAL WORKS WITHOUT THE PATIENT
SEE MORE SERIOUSLY. THE OTHER
ATTENTION THE CHANGES ARE BASED
ON A COULD SOMEHOW PEOPLE
LITTLE IN YOUR LIFE. THAT THEY
HAVE AN EPISODE. LEARN A
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT CAUSES THEM
TO NEED ASSISTANCE. AND THEN
WITH ONE EPISODE OF ARE
RELATIVELY BRIEF RECEIPT OF
FLEXIBLE SERVICES- AND FORTY
EIGHT MONTHS THAT THEY CAN
FOREVER FOR THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES MANAGED TO AVOID-
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WOULD CAUGHT
THEIR CHILDREN TO HAVE. TO LIVE
IN THE PROPERTY. BOTH
DESTRUCTION TO BE COMPLETELY
FALL. PEOPLE DID NOT LIVE MANY
LIVES IN THE PROTECTION. THE
PEOPLE IN THIS PROCESS. WHO DID
EVER. RIGHT THEY WORK. THEY
MIGHT GROUPS TWENTY FOUR OF.
WORKS THEY GET EVERYTHING THEY
NEEDED TO DO TO MOVE FROM
WELFARE TO WORK IN EVER
SUPPORTING THEIR CHILDREN AND
NOW THEY FIND THEMSELVES
UNEMPLOYED PERHAPS SECTORS OF
THE ECONOMY. THAT WILL BE- SORT
OF- DELIBERATED FOR YEARS. WHEN
A PERSON COMES INTO OUR OFFICE
IN MAY NEED THE FULL COMPLEMENT
OF FLEXIBLE SERVICES TO
RETRAIN- FOR DIFFERENT INDUSTRY
AND THEY BUTTE THEIR TWENTY
FOUR MONTHLY COLUMN SORRY WE
CAN'T HELP YOU. IT'S INCREDIBLY
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO DID NINE
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO DO
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO GIVE
THEM THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF
SUPPORT SERVICES SO THAT THEY
CAN WHETHER ANOTHER RECESSION
THAT THEY HAD ABSOLUTELY NO
ABILITY TO CONTROL. THE OTHER
REASON- SUPPORT MANAGER IS THAT
TIME LIMITS ARE INCREDIBLY
COMPLICATED TIME CONSUMING
CUMBERSOME AND DIFFICULT TO
ADMINISTER THE RAND CORPORATION
THE MATH MATHEMATICA POLICY
RESEARCH IN THE DFS STAKEHOLDER
GROUP. THAT WAS REQUIRED IN
LEGISLATION HAVE ALL CONCLUDED
THAT THAT THAT TIME WHEN THE
WORK WEEK SPAN- MANAGING TIME
CLOCK IS UNPRODUCTIVE INTAKES
ARE WORK AWAY FROM HELPING
CLIENTS WITH THE REAL BUSINESS.
OF ADDRESSING THE THINGS THAT
WE CAN ADDRESS SO THAT THEY CAN
THEY CAN MOVE IN TO WORK. WE I
WOULD REQUIRED THE SENATE
MECCA. CAN I LOG YES YEAH CAN I
ASK YOU TO WIND UP YOUR- YOUR
COMMENT SIR AND MA'AM I CALLED
IT IN SO WE SPEND A LOT OF TIME
TALKING TECH AND- ABOUT THEIR
TIME CLOCKS. WHICH MONTH COUNT
WHICH DON'T WANT TO JUST THE
TWENTY FOUR MONTH CLOCK IS JUST
A FORTY EIGHT MONTH CLOCK. THAT
TURNED OUT NOT SPENDING HELPING
PEOPLE ACHIEVE THEIR GOAL. I AM
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT THAT
TIME IS COUNTER PRODUCTIVE AS
WELL. ON BEING ANACHRONISTIC
POLICIES THAT WERE BASED ON
BIAS AND PREJUDICE NOT A I AM
NEED TO GO WE START WITH A BABY
TO AT FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COM IN SUPPORT. WHAT
HAVE AN OUTLET KALRA JAVA WELL
PROVIDE AN IDEA WE ALSO LONG
REPORTER BILL I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU IN WE COOPER BY ALL
OF THE TECH WORLD WITH PEOPLE
WE PROVIDER THANK FOR YOUR FOR
YOUR. THANK YOU FOR YOUR COME
OKAY ANY OTHER AND OTHERS IN.
PLEASE JUST THE NAME FILIATION
AND YOUR POSITION. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE ANY OPPOSITION.
ANY OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY SEVEN UPON ONE. ON
THE PHONE LINES PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO WE DO HAVE. OVERALL
REBEKAH GONZALEZ PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND- GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. SINGLE IF YOU HAD
TO GET THEM STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SEEING AND HEARING.
LINE SIXTY SIX YOU'RE OPEN.
FIVE SIXTY SIX IS YOUR PHONE
YOU'RE A. WHAT ARE YOU LIBERTY
YEAH. YOU HAPPEN AT A USED HELD.
AND DUMPED THE PORT. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT ORDER.
NOT ON THE PHONE LINES. RIGHT
TO NO ONE HERE PRESENT. LET'S
BRING IT TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. SEEING
HEARING NON WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE
I'M SORRY DOCTOR RAMBLE. I'LL
BE BRIEF BECAUSE I'M SURE YOU
WANT TO GET BACK TO YOUR
DAUGHTER BUT- DIDN'T WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO ACTUALLY
APPRECIATE YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD- I SPEND A
LOT OF TIME LOOKING AT THE CAL
WORKS PROGRAM AND- THE TIME
CLOCKS HAVE NEVER REALLY MADE
SENSE TO ME EITHER ESPECIALLY
AS THEY ARE COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
DOES THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT
MANY IN OUR COMMUNITY ARE GOING
TO NEED TO HERE SHORTLY I THINK
IT'S IMPERATIVE FOR US TO GET
THE PROGRAM DONE RIGHT AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THIS
MEASURE WAS BROUGHT FORWARD SO.
HOPEFULLY YOUR DAUGHTER GETS
THROUGH THAT WHAT YOU DID HERE
TODAY HELPS OTHER SINGLE MOMS
HELPS OTHER PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRYING JUST TO MAKE THEIR
BETTER AS WELL. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
ACTUALLY I WILL USE DOCTOR
ARAMBULA COMMENTS AS MY CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST NAY VOTE.
THANK YOU. THE MOTION AND
SECOND PLACE TO GROW. THE
MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS WRATH HI RES HI
MATHIS MATHIS I ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE FLORA AYE FLORA
AYE FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN I GIPSON
GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN. STONE
STONE HI THE CURRENT VOTED
SEVEN TO ZERO. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THAT MOVES US NOW TO THE
CHAIRS TO BILLS WAIT THE FIRST
ONE IS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB.
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY ONE. WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR YOU MAY
PRESENT. THANK YOU- MEMBERS AND
CHAIR. AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
ONE WILL CREATE THE DEPARTMENT
OF EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT
ALIGNING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ENSURING FINALLY A
STREAMLINED GOVERNMENT
STRUCTURE FOR EARLY CHILD
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS. WE ALL
KNOW THAT THE FIRST FIVE YEARS
OFLIFE FOR THE MOST IMPORTANT
FOR A CHILD'S BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
AND PROVIDING QUALITY EARLY
EDUCATION DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
DURING THESE CRITICAL YEARS
ENHANCES A CHILD'S OPPORTUNITY
TO SUCCEED FURTHER IN COP IN
SCHOOL COLLEGE AND ULTIMATELY
THE WORK FORCE. OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM IS GOVERNED UNDER A
VARIETY OF STATE DEPARTMENTS
AND AGENCIES THIS BIFURCATED
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE OFTEN
FORCES. PARENTS AND PROVIDERS
SHOULD NEVER GET MULTIPLE
CONTRACTS AND ENGAGE WITH
MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS SOMETIMES
EVEN SEEING A DISRUPTION IN
SERVICES. A STRONG YOU SEE
SYSTEM JUST LIKE ANY OTHER
SEGMENT OF OUR EDUCATION CAN
ONLY EXIST. WITH A STRONG
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE WHICH
OPERATES TO GUARANTEE OUR EARLY
CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
ARE CHEATING EDUCATIONAL GOALS
AND PROMOTING EQUITY AS
INTENDED. SINCE THE START OF
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC IT
HAS BECOME INCREDIBLY CLEAR HOW
IMPERATIVE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION PROGRAMS ARE FOR MANY
OF CALIFORNIA'S FAMILIES
INCLUDING OUR CENTRAL WORKERS.
THE RELIANCE ON THESE PROGRAMS
AND THE RECENT NEED AND
SCRAMBLE TO STREAMLINE AN
ORGANIZED ACROSS DEPARTMENTS TO
PROVIDE EARLY CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS IN LIGHT
OF THE PANDEMIC. ONLY FOR THEIR
ILLUSTRATES THE NEED TO HAVE A
CENTRALIZED GOVERNING STRUCTURE.
MY OFFICE CONTINUES TO ENGAGE
IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
ENSURE THAT AS THIS PROPOSAL
DEVELOPS AND STAKEHOLDERS
CONCERNS ARE MITIGATED IN
FUTURE AMENDMENTS THIS
DEPARTMENT TRULY SERVES THE
CHILDREN. FAMILIES AND
PROVIDERS AT ISN'T AS IT IS
INTENDED TO. THERE'S NO DOUBT
THAT HIGH QUALITY EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION CAN BE THE
GREATEST EQUALIZER THE
CALIFORNIA CAN PROVIDE FOR
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN. AND THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT
WILL ENSURE THAT WE PROVIDE
THESE SOCIO ECONOMICALLY AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY TRANSFORMATIVE
PROGRAMS IN AN EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT MANNER. TO SPEAK ON
THE MATTER OR SCOTT MORE
DIRECTOR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
COULD THEN GO AND PATRICIA
LOZANO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
EARLY EDGE CALIFORNIA AND I
UNDERSTAND OUR SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC EDUCATION. TONY
THURMOND WILL OFFER SOME CC
COMMENTS AS WELL. THANK YOU
FIRST WITNESS IN SUPPORT PLEASE.
YES HI GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS SCOTT MORE AND I AM WITH
KIDDING OKAY DANGO IS THE
LARGEST PRESCHOOL AND CHILDCARE
PROVIDER
TO
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES- YOU
DON'T HAVE. MANY DIFFERENT-
DEPARTMENT- YOU HAVE JUST ONE
CHILD- AND ONE CHILD WHO NEEDS-
A HOLISTIC- SUPPORT SYSTEM- TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED- LET ME JUST GIVE A QUICK
CONCRETE EXAMPLE- SO KIDDING GO
NOW WE PROVIDE MANY DIFFERENT
SERVICES- NOT JUST CHILDCARE
BUT WE PROVIDE REALLY. I'D
REALLY CHILD HEALTH NUTRITION
SERVICE I COULD GO ON HOWEVER.
IF YOU'RE A PARENT OF A CHILD
THAT NEEDS EARLY INTERVENTION
DEVELOPMENTAL- OR SPEECH
THERAPY- YOU MAY GO AND- GO TO
THE REGIONAL CENTER- AND
REQUEST- FOR YOUR CHILD TO BE
OBSERVED- AND THEY MAY FIND
THAT YOUR CHILD ACTUALLY DOES
QUALIFY- FOR SPEECH THERAPY-
HOWEVER- IF YOU ASK FOR SPEECH
THERAPY- THAT IS IN CONJUNCTION
WITH FULL THEY CHILD CARE- YOU
MAY VERY WELL HERE THAT THAT
NOT AVAILABLE- THAT THAT'S NOT
WHAT. THE LAW CENTER DOES AND
THAT BUT WHAT EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES IS ABOUT.
THAT ULTIMATELY- MEANS THAT
THAT FAMILY MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF SPEECH
THERAPY- OR THEY MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF CHILD
CARE SIR I DO NEED FOR THE
REALITY IS. OKAY THANK YOU- SO
RUN WRAPPING UP- NOW IS THE
TIME- TO LAY THE FOUNDATION TO
REBUILD OUR CHILD CARE SYSTEM.
NOT HOW IT WAS BUT HOW WE WOULD
LIKE TO ENVISION IT TO BE ONE
THAT REFLECT THE NEEDS OF THE
WHOLE CHILD. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
CALIFANO PLAN AND THE EXPECTED
DIRECTOR OF EARLY AT CALIFORNIA
FOR NONPROFIT ADVOCATING FOR
THE BAT BUT THE BALL A LITTLE
DIRTY PROGRAMS FOR KIDS THING
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY ONE. I KOBE NINETEEN
HAPPENED LIMITED THE NEED FOR
DEEP NEAR DEPARTMENT NOW MORE
THAN EVER WE NEED A CENTRALIZED
COORDINATED SUSPEND NAME ONLY%
NOT TO RESPOND TO THE
INCREASING USE OF FAMILY. EARLY
LEARNING A CHARACTER PROGRAMS
ARE YOU BEST HELP THREE WE
OPENING OUR ECONOMY AND OUR
RAPID RECOVERY FROM THE
RECESSION. WE NEED ACCESS TO
QUALITY AND PROPER CARE THE
CALIFORNIA AND GO BACK TO WORK
AND FOR KEY TO CONTINUE THEIR
LEARNING. CREATING A NEW. OF IN
THE CHAPEL DEVELOPMENT OUT
THERE A TO CHAT SUPPORT THE
WHOLE CHILD WHOLE FAMILY THAT
WILL SUPPORT FAMILY CONNECTED
THINK CHILD CARE EARLY LEARNING
HEALTH SERVICES. DURING THESE.
DIFFICULT TIME BY COORDINATING
PROGRAM SERVICES THE CREATING
THE CREATION OF A NEW
DEPARTMENT WILL ALSO RESULT. IN
THAT TIME LONG TERM FINANCIAL
STAVING. OTHER STATE AT THAT
HAVE A LINE THEIR EARLY DURING
BECAUSE SOME HAVE FOUND
BENEFITS ON DOING SO. APPLE
WATCH YOU THINK CONNECTICUT
GEORGIAN MASSACHUSETTS ARE JUST
A FEW STATES THAT HAVE CREATED
A DEDICATED EARLY CHILDHOOD
AGENCY. SOME OF THE DEMONSTRATE
BENEFITS INCLUDE WE DO THINK
ADMINISTRATOR ADMINISTRATE
DUPLICATION COORDINATING AND
PRIORITIZING DATA COLLECTION
AND IMPROVING INTER AGENCY
COLLABORATION WHICH WE NEED
REALLY NEED IN CALIFORNIA. WE
ALSO ONE AT HIGHLIGHT HOW THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY-
BELIEVE IT'S RELEASED ITS BLU
RAY OF THE COMMISSION REPORT.
OUR STATE STATED THAT WE MIGHT.
BILL THAT COURSE IN THE- THIS
STUDY. INCLUDE THE GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE INTEGRATED FUNDING
STREAMS AND ACCOUNTABLE
COORDINATION OF ALL PROGRAM
WITH EFFECTIVE LAKE COUNTY OR
REGIONAL LEVEL BODY. EVEN
THOUGH WE'RE FACING I'M PRETTY
GOOD I THINK PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC ECONOMIC CHALLENGES WE-
AN OPPORTUNITY TO FORTY FIVE
ARE ARE A LEARNING SYSTEM IN
FACT. OPEN BANKING CRISIS I
UNDERSCORED BOTH THE NEED AND
URGENCY TO BUILD BACK HERE AND%
STREAMLINED WITH THEM FOR
CALIFORNIA. FOR THE THREE WE
WOULD. ASK FOR YOUR EYES VOTE
FOR A. TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY ONE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
NOW WILL MOVE TO OUR
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION MISTER THURMAN. MR
THURMAN ARE YOU THERE. MR
THURMAN. I WILL WILL HOLD ON
WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE. OPPOSED TO AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY ONE. YES I
AM OKAY MY IT. MY NAME IS
CAMILLE JALEO WITH CALIFORNIA
RIGHT TO LIFE COMMITTEE.
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY.
DO YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU
ON THIS IMPORTANT MATTER. AND
PRECISELY BECAUSE OF ITS
IMPORTANCE WE ASK YOU TO REJECT
THIS BILL AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
ONE WE WILL NOT ACCOMPLISH THE
VISION THE SHADED BY SPEAKER
RENDON HUNDRED NAY PAGE BLUE
RIBBON COMMITTEE REPORT. THAT
CREATED THIS PROGRAM. EVEN WHEN
THE COMMITTEE HAD COMPLETED ITS
TASK THEY WERE STILL ASKING
THEMSELVES NOW WHAT HAVE WE ON
THIS PAPER WHAT IS IT WE NEED
TO BRING ABOUT. AND THAT'S WHAT
I'M HERE TO ASK YOU TO THINK
ABOUT TODAY WHAT IS THE
INTENDED GOAL FOR CHILDREN FOR
EDUCATION FOR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES. BECAUSE THIS BILL
FAILS TO FAR IT FAR SHORT OF
BRINGING ABOUT ANY SUCCESSFUL
GOAL. THE BILL WILL CREATE
GOVERNMENT PRIVATE COMMUNITY
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS P AND
DOWN THE STATE FUNDED WITH TAX
DOLLARS. THESE GROUPS WILL BE
TASKED WITH DELIVERING MENTAL
HEALTH COUNSELING THROUGH THE
SCHOOL SYSTEM TO OUR CHILDREN.
THOUGH THE PROMOTIONAL MATERIAL
SPEAKS OF ALSO HELPING FAMILIES
THERE'S LITTLE CAN NO MENTION
OF FAMILIES IN THE BILL. WE BY
THIS TIME IT GETS TO THE
CHILDREN IT WILL BE SO WATERED
DOWN MONEY DRAINED OUT OF IT
THAT THERE WILL BE NO PROBLEMS
GOAL AVAILABLE IT'S APPARENT
THAT YOU HAVE COMPASSION FOR
WHAT YOU SEE IS A LACK OF
EQUITY AND THE CALIFORNIA
LIFESTYLE. BUT THIS BILL WILL
ONLY EXPAND THAT BLACK DRIVE
WEDGES BETWEEN CHILD AND
PARENT. OVER BURDEN OF SCHOOL
SYSTEM BY TURNING IT AND GOING
MENTAL HEALTH REPAIR SHOP.
PLEASE DO THINK OF THE
CHILDREN. AND SAYING NO TO AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. ON THE PHONE LINES
FOR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
THERE'S A COUPLE QUEUING UP ON
THE PHONE LINE OKAY THANK YOU.
A MOMENT. OKAY. THANK YOU HELLO
UP IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY. ON AB TWENTY
FIVE A LINE FIFTY THREE. NINE
THIRTY THREE THE LINE IS OPEN.
ONE THIRTY THREE WE DON'T MEET
YOUR FOLLOW HELLO WE CAN HEAR
YOU. WHAT WHAT MY NAME IS
WILLIAM MAHER ON THE OTHER GIRL
PUBLISHER QUITE LINE NEW BUT
HIS NATIONAL SECURITY
ORGANIZATION WE'VE BEEN IN
BUSINESS FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS-
WE RISE IN IN IN- COMPLETE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL- I'LL
TELL YOU JUST YOU CAN JUST PICK
OUT A COUPLE THINGS FIRST. DO
YOU FOR BEING HERE- TO ME.
BEING IF. OKAY BUT THAT WOULD
ATTEMPT TO HELP IN GO FOR. DOES
THAT YOU ARE LOOKING FOR A
QUALITY OF OUTCOME NOT BE
QUALITY. OF OPPORTUNITY. THAT'S
THE FIRST YEAH BUT THE FIRST
OBSERVATION THE LAST ONE IS-
HAVE YOU FOLKS EVER CONSIDERED
THE RAMIFICATIONS REGARDING
THE- SEPARATION OF POWERS OF
THE- LEGISLATURE DELEGATING ALL
OF THESE DIRECTIVES TO UP SOME
COMMITTEES AND SOME ENTITIES
WOULD HAVE NOT YET BEEN
CREATED. AND YOU'RE COMING YEAR
LEGISLATORS OUR OVER TO THE
BUREAUCRACY AND I WOULD REALLY
LIKE TO COMMENT ON THAT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION WE WON'T
TAKE TESTIMONY BUT WE'LL TAKE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL UNLESS THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION IS THERE MISTER
THURMAN WOULD LOVE TO GET YOUR
TESTIMONY. NINE SEVENTY FOUR A
GOOD AFTERNOON- I WILL BE READY
WHEN YOU- LET ME KNOW YOU LIKE
ME TO BEGIN YOU MAY BEGIN.
WELCOME THANK YOU THANK YOU-
TONY THURMOND STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF IT IF THIS IS
ON THE- ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY ONE IS THAT CORRECT
YES THAT'S CORRECT. THANK YOU
I'D LIKE TO THANK GOD. THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR THE BILL- AND-
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE-
TESTIMONY- THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. WE
ARE FAMILIAR WITH THE BILL IN
ITS INTENT TO CREATE A NEW WAY
OF DELIVERING CHILDCARE
PROGRAMS- IN THE STATE. YEAH
AND- AS WE LEARNED ABOUT THE
BILL WE'VE ENGAGED IN
CONVERSATION TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT HOW THE BILL WOULD WORK
SINCE IT WOULD CHANGE
SIGNIFICANTLY- PROGRAMMING
THAT'S OFFERED AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. AS WE'RE LEARNING
ABOUT THE BILL WE EARNED THAT
THE GOAL OF THE BILL AND THE
INTENT IN THE DIRECTION OF THE
BILL AND THE INTEREST IN THE
GOVERNOR- IS TO. STREAMLINE HOW
CHILDCARE PROGRAMS ARE
DELIVERED AND THAT WOULD
PROVIDE BETTER SERVICE- FOR
CALIFORNIANS- WHILE WE'RE STILL
LEARNING ABOUT THE BILL WE
SUPPORT THAT GOAL ANY GOAL THAT
WOULD- IMPROVE DELIVERY OF
SERVICE- FOR CALIFORNIANS- WEEK
FEELS IMPORTANT TO SUPPORT. AND
SO WE ENGAGED EARLY ON- PRIOR
TO COPE WITH NINETEEN ENGAGE
EARLY ON IN A PROCESS. TO TALK
TO YOU HOW THE BILL WOULD WORK
IN TO TALK TO THE KIND OF
CHANGE THAT WOULD MEAN FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND OTHER AGENCIES.
THAT WOULD BE DIRECTLY INVOLVED
AND- WE'RE WE'RE WILLING TO
CONTINUE DOING THAT- POLICIES I
ONLY JUST RECENTLY OUR TEAM
WILL JUST RECENTLY LEARNED OF
TODAY'S HEARING OPPORTUNITY- WE
WE'VE BEEN THAT YOU BUY A MAC I
JUST WOKE. ON OUR EDUCATIONAL.
THE COLBERT INETEEN AND THAT
WERE YOU AWARE FOCUS ON THAT.
AND HAD NOT. TO TAKE ANY ACTION
AS RELATES TO THE BILL WITH AND
REALLY WEREN'T CLEAR- ON
WHETHER OR NOT TO DEAL WITH THE
MOVING FORWARD WE UNDERSTAND
THAT IT IS NOW- BUT BECAUSE
WE'VE BEEN IN THE PAST YEAR OF.
HOPING OUR ONE THOUSAND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- TO MOVE- JUSTICE
LEARNING- TO GET COMPUTERS AND
DEVICES FOR KIDS YOUDON'T HAVE
THEM. AND THEN TO PREPARE FOR
THE ULTIMATE RE OPENING OF OUR
SCHOOLS AND HOW TO DO SO
SAFELY. WE'VE BEEN A FOCUS ON
THAT EXCLUSIVELY WOULD NOT TAKE
A POSITION ON ANY BILLS AND SO
WE SUPPORT THE GOALS AT THIS
BILL ARTICULATE- WE HAVE
NOTHING TO OFFER. BY WAY OF
OPPOSITION WE JUST HAVEN'T BEEN
TAKING ANY POSITIONS ON BILLS
AND WE WEREN'T AWARE THAT ANY
BILLS FROM MOVING FORWARD
BECAUSE OF COCA NINETEEN. AND
OF COURSE BECAUSE OF THE
CURRENTLY ANNOUNCED FINANCIAL
POSITION OF THE STATE BUT WE'RE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR- GRATEFUL TO
THE AUTHOR- THE UP AS A GREAT
TRACK RECORD. OF SUPPORTING
PROGRAMS FOR A CHILD CARE AND
EARLY EDUCATION- WE WANT TO
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE OFFICE OF
THE AUTHOR IT'S BEEN. VERY
COLLABORATIVE- WITH US- IT WE
SUPPORT THE GOALS OF THIS BILL
ARTICULATE- WE WILL LIKE THIS
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO- MAIN
GATE ON THE BILL NOW THAT WE
KNOW THAT THE BILL IS MOVING
FORWARD- AND JUST TO. SET UP
NOW WE ARE STILL FOCUS
PRIMARILY ON OUR EFFORTS. TO
ADDRESS IMPACT OF CODE NINETEEN
WE SUPPORT THE GOALS OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU QUESTIONS. A
HALF. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER SUPERINTEND THAT ANYONE
ELSE ONLY. THANK WITH ANY ALSO
LIKE TO GIVE US NAME YOUR FOR.
AND YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL.
KEVIN UP THE IN COALITION
CALIFORNIA WATER RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION TO SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE. ON
THE PHONE LINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE ON THE PHONE TWO. BUT THIS
TIME. RIGHT THANK YOU. MOVE TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
MISTER MATHIS. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR I REALLY LIKE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE I AGREE WITH.
A LOT OF THE OTHER CONCERNS ON
THE FISCAL SIDE OF THIS WE HAVE
A LOT OF THINGS GOING ON WE
HAVE A NEW RECESSION GOING. MY
CONCERN IS THAT WE MOVE THIS
FORWARD AND JUST THE FUNDING IS
NOT THERE TO BE ABLE TO DO
THIS- I DO RECOGNIZE THIS IS
THE POLICY COMMITTEE SIDE I
REALLY DO LIKE THE POLICY OF
THIS- I KNOW WE'VE WORKED. TO A
LOT OF YEARS TO PUT THINGS
TOGETHER TO PUSH FOR A WHOLE
FAMILY CARE AND WRAPAROUND
SERVICES- TO MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY CAN NETWORK- THEY HAD
ALL THE PROVIDERS CAN
COMMUNICATE TO PROVIDE THE BEST
CARE NOT JUST TO AN INDIVIDUAL
BUT TO THE ENTIRE FAMILY. I
WISH WE WERE IN DIFFERENT TIMES.
YOU KNOW WE WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN
ABLE TO BRAG ABOUT BEING THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD IN A- VERY- OPTIMISTIC
THAT WILL RECOVER FROM THIS
RECESSION BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
FOR WRAPAROUND SERVICES BUT I
THINK RIGHT NOW. I'M GONNA HAVE
TO HOLD OFF ON SUPPORTING THIS
IN JUST LAY OFF TODAY- TO SEE
HOW THIS GETS THROUGH ON THE
FINANCIAL SIDE WITH
APPROPRIATIONS AND EVERYTHING
ELSE AND MAYREVISE- BUT I DO
HOPE TO SEE IT ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER SMITH. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE FROM THE COMMITTEE. I HATE
SEEING HEARING THAT BUT I'M
SURE YOU MAY CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND ON AB
TWENTY FIVE ANYONE CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE. THE MOTION IS THE
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS RADIUS HI
RES HI MATHIS. MATHIS NOT
VOTING ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI
FLORA. FLOOR NOT VOTING
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I'D GIVE SAN.
GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN STONE HI
STONE HI THE CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO. THANK YOU AND I
THINK THE ROLE WILL BE OPEN FOR
AT THE MEMBERS FOR A LITTLE
WHILE LONGER THAT TAKES US TO
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB THIRTY
ONE THIRTY FOUR. AND THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND VENTURE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR DOWN TO MEMBERS.
AB THIRTY ONE OR THIRTY SEP
THAT THIRTY ONE THIRTY FOUR
EXTENSIVE REFUGEE CASH
ASSISTANCE OR RCA. PROGRAM
DURING THIS PRECARIOUS TIME.
IMAGINE FILLING A WAR ZONE AND
RISING TO A NEW COUNTRY
COMPLETELY ALONE WITH NO
FRIENDS OR FAMILY. I NEED TO
LEARN A NEW LANGUAGE NAVIGATE A
NEW JOB MARKET AND SECURE JOB
ALL WHILE TRYING TO STAY SAFE
DURING THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IS NO FEET. IS NO EASY
FEAT. CURRENTLY REFUGEES WERE
ABLE BODIED ADULTS WITHOUT
DEPENDENTS ARE ABLE TO ACCESS
THE RCA PROGRAM WHICH IS
COMPLETELY FEDERALLY FUNDED AT
THIS TIME. TO SECURE CASH
ASSISTANCE WHICH MIRRORS ARE
CAL WORKS PROGRAM WELL THEY
WERE ABLE TO SECURE EMPLOYMENT.
ALL THIS IS A GREAT BENEFIT IT
ONLY LASTS EIGHT MONTHS. FOR
MANY WHO WOULD OTHERWISE
QUALIFY FOR THINGS LIKE SOCIAL
SECURITY OR DISABILITY BENEFITS
THIS ISN'T EVEN ENOUGH TIME TO
SUBMIT THEIR APPLICATION AND
SECURE THEIR BENEFITS BEFORE
FINDING THEMSELVES WITHOUT ANY
ASSISTANCE. SINCE THE START OF
THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC THE
ECONOMIC REALITY HAS GROWN MORE
STARK AS YOU ALL KNOW. MAKING
IT EVEN MORE DIFFICULT FOR
THESE NEW REFUGEES TO SECURE
EMPLOYMENT IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AB ONE AB THIRTY
ONE THIRTY FOUR SIMPLY CODIFIES
A MATCH TO THE RCA PROGRAM BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CEMENTING CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO RICK RESETTLING
REFUGEES AND LEAVING THEM TO
SELF SUFFICIENCY AND EXTENDING
THE PROGRAM FROM EIGHT TO
SIXTEEN MONTHS. WHEN ASSISTED
UPON RESETTLEMENT REFUGEES CAN
MORE QUICKLY LEAD LIVES OF SELF
SUFFICIENCY WITHIN CALIFORNIA.
FOR THE MORE THEY THEN TURN
AROUND TO PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
ECONOMIC AND CULTURAL
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE STATE
INCLUDING UP TO SEVENTEEN
BILLION AND SEVENTY IN
SEVENTEEN BILLION IN SPENDING
POWER. IT IS FOR THESE REASONS
I ASK YOU TO FROM CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT. TO REFUGEES IN
SUPPORTING THEM DURING THE
SECOND I'M A COOLEY PRECARIOUS
TIME. TO SPEAK MORE ON THE
MATTER IS OSAMA. WHAT MUKADA ON
FROM THE COUNCIL ON AMERICAN
ISLAMIC RELATIONS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND KEVIN AS LONG IN
FROM THE CALIFORNIA COALITION A
WELFARE RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE THE CONFLICT
IN CLEVELAND. A YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU WERE GETTING SOME
INTERFERENCE THE RIO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A GOOD MORNING EVERYONE-
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR
MEDICARE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- CARAMEL BUT THEN I'M
HERE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AT THE TOP
ON AMERICAN COMIC RELATIONS
CARE. THE NATION'S LARGEST MOST
LOOK ALIKE ARE GRADUATING WITH
OVER TWENTY FIVE OFFICES.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AS A CO
SPONSOR FOR AT THIRTY ONE
THIRTY FOUR I'M. HERE TO URGE
YOUR AYE BOTH. AS INSURANCE.
YOUR AN ADDITIONAL MONTH THIRTY
CASH. PAYMENT FUNDED BY THE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO BE PAID. END OF
WITH REFUGEE STATUS AFTER THAT
FEDERALLY FUNDED CASH EIGHT
BENEFIT AT THE DOCTOR. DIRT IN
OVER THIRTY THOUSAND. THREE
SETTLED FOR. ALONG THE PATH
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS IN ADDITION
TO THE THOUSANDS MORE ACROSS
THE STATE. THE EXTERNAL TO THE
INDIVIDUAL CARRYING. THE
PERSECUTION OF WORK NOT. AS IT
INVOLVES DISPLAYED FROM EVERY
THAT LAWYER TO THEM INCLUDING.
BUT NOT LIMITED TO. OCCUPATION
LIKE. CULTURE EDUCATION. ****
WOODLAND AND BETTER LIVING
AMONG OTHER THINGS. THE CURRENT
FEDERAL PARTY A KROGER WITH THE
MINISTER THE DAY TO THE CAL
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES A
LOT FOR EIGHT MONTHS SETTLEMENT
DANTE REFUGEES OFTENTIMES
CATTLE IN THE STATE WITH THEIR
FAMILIES ARE EXPECTED TO A
GUEST TO RESETTLEMENT HOLDEN
LEARNED ENGLISH PARA. GET AN
AFFRONT TO KEEP YOUR MOTIVE
FROM EACH ONE OF THE GIRLS TO
THE AMERICAN SOCIETY AND
CULTURE. AMONG MUCH MORE. GOOD
WINDOW CLIPS FAMILY ARE OFTEN.
IN A PLAGUE WHERE THEY HAVE
SACRIFICED INCOME. THE TIME FOR
THE TOP IN A- INTO AMERICANS.
COULD LEAD SO SILLY MENTALLY
AND- JUST ONE FIND. PEOPLE
CLASS THANK. KEEP THEIR TALK
THAT WOULD IN THE FLOW ACT THE
EIGHT MONTH PERIOD. AS WE
CANNOT CARE YOUR MONEY OF OUR
AND YOUR RIGHT CLIENTS THAT WE
SERVE. SENATE PERIOD FIFTEEN
MONTHS BY AT A GOOD EIGHT
HUNDRED MY PERIOD WITH GIVE A
MORE. CARRIED FOR THE- TO ALLOW
THEM. TO PROPERLY INTEGRATE THE
CALIFORNIA. FURTHER ENSURING
THAT THE STRONGEST FOR THE
SECOND EIGHT MONTH PERIOD IN
LIFE AND BASED ON. TWENTY
ELIGIBILITY IT'S ABOUT MOST
INQUIRE AT THE INSURED. THAT
THERE'S NO GAP IN THE CASH
ASSISTANCE FAMILIES OR SLEEPING
WITH THE PREPEND ON A MUCH. IN
NINETEEN HELP ON DEMOCRATIC
SPOKESMAN IF THE SHORTCOMINGS
OF THE FREE. FUNDING AND IF YOU
FAMILY SACRAMENTO COUNTY ACROSS
THE STATE. NEW HOME RECENTLY
ENTERED THE COUNTRY AND A FACE
TO THE CARE OF NOT BEING ABLE
TO AFFORD THEIR DEMANDING
LIFESTYLE. MANY HAVE YET TO
HAVE THE WORK IT CAN THAT YOU
CAN ARE PORTED. THAT IS CALLED
WITH APPEARED IN IN THEIR TOWN.
YOU TO THEIR BACKGROUND AND IN
LIGHT I URGE YOU CAN TO VOTE I
AM THAT BILL SO MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS BUT THAT
KEPT. SEVEN AT THE CLOSE OF
JOHN WELL RIGHT FOR. SOMEONE
THE FOR. SPONSORED WHAT'S YOUR
THE BILL WOULD A. THE ONLY
POINT I WANT TO MAKE THE JOB
FIFTY THAT PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE WHICH 50% FEDERAL FUNDING
50% STATE FUNDING. SO TO BILL
WOULD BASICALLY PROVIDE VITAL
250% FEDERAL FUNDING 30% STATE
FUNDING BY EXTENDING UP TO SIX
MONTHS WHICH TO URGE ARRIVAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WOULD
ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO REGISTER
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE US YOUR
NAME YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION. WE'RE NOT TAKING
FURTHER TESTIMONY AT THIS POINT.
GO AHEAD PLEASE BY THE ADVOCATE
HERE NOTHING CENTER L<c.cyan>G WITH</c>
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE LEGISLATIONTHANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE. HELLO YES MISTER
CHAIR JESSICA BAKULA WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND ALSO A PROUD HOST
FAMILY FOR REFUGEE FAMILY. AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
POLICY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE. THERE ARE TWO ON
THE THREE ON THE PHONE LINES.
ANYONE ELSE NINE SEVEN. IN
SUPPORT. HELLO HELLO GO AHEAD
YEAH. THANK YOU MISTER- VICE
CHAIR MADAM CHAIR IN THE
COMMITTEE OF THREE WONDERFUL
EFFORTS- MY NAME THEM ON AND
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR-
UNLESS BY- UNLESS BACK IS A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
ACTIVELY WORKS OFF THE
GRASSROOTS LEVEL TO ASSIST
REFUGEES IN THE SACRAMENTO
VALLEY. AND WHAT WE NOTICED- ON
THIS LEVEL OF THAT MANY OF THE
FAMILIES ARE LACKING RESOURCES
AND I'M NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR
THEMSELVES. THE BIG BIG HYGIENE
CLEANING ITEMS YES THANK YOU
SIR WERE NOT ABLE TO TAKE
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY THIS TIME
BUT JUST REGISTER SUPPORT. FOR
THE BILL. OKAY YEAH SO I
SUPPORT FOR THE I SUPPORT THE
BILL AND I URGE- YOUR VOTE I'M
NOT ABLE. PERFECT THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE SUPPORT.
RIGHT IS THERE IS THERE
OPPOSITION. WE'RE HEARING A. B.
THIRTY ONE THIRTY FOUR. BY CHAR
RAISE THEIR OPPOSITION. OR ANY
OTHER SUPPORT. RIGHT HEARING
NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
WAS MATHIS. THANK YOU- MADAM
CHAIR I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE LOOK AT-
ARE LEGAL REFUGEES. NO NO
THERE'S A LOT OF. POLITICIZING
THAT HAPPENS OUT THERE BUT
THESE ARE THE FOLKS THAT HAVE
GONETHROUGH THE VETTING
PROCESS AND EVERYTHING ELSE AND
ARE JUST TRYING TO- MAKE NEW
LIVE SOMEWHERE SAFE WHERE
FREEDOM COMES FIRST AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE- YOU LOOKING
AT THAT AND TAKING NOTE OF THAT
AND ALL THE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU WHAT
ELSE WAS MAY TWENTY. OKAY
ANYONE ELSE ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBER RIGHT. SIGNAL. YOU MAY
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
EUROPE OF THANK YOU WE DO HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THEIR PREPARATIONS RAY YES.
REYES HI MATT THIS MATHIS I
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE FLORA.
FRIEDMAN REMAIN I'D GIVE SEN
GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN EYES DOWN BY THE
STONE HI THE CURRENT VOTE IS
SEVEN ZERO. THANK YOU THAT
MOTION PASSES MATTER COULD I
ADD ON APOLOGIZE I WAS TALKING
TO THE MOISTURE YES. I WASN'T
PAYING ATTENTION. THE MOTION IS
THE PAST THEIR PREPARATIONS
FLORA HI LAURA HI THE CURRENT
VOTE IS EIGHT ZERO. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH AND NOW
WOULD DO TAKE ROLE ON ABSENT
MEMBERS PLEASE. I WE CAN SET
CALENDAR THE CURRENT VOTE IS
SEVEN ZERO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN HI THE FINAL VOTE
IS EIGHT ZERO. THANK YOU. FILE
ITEM ONE AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
FOUR THE CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN
ZERO MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN I
AM. THE FINAL VOTE IS EIGHT
ZERO. I FILE ITEM THREE THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ZERO. TAKE
YOUR TIME MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN HI. THE FINAL VOTE
IS SIX ZERO. I FILE ITEM FOR
THE URRENT VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN HI.
FINAL VOTE IS EIGHT ZERO. I'M
FILE ITEM SIX THE CURRENT BUT
IS SEVEN ZERO MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN HI THE FINAL VOTE
IS EIGHT ZERO. I FILE ITEM
EIGHT THE CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN
ZERO MAIENSCHEIN MANGE AYE AYE.
HEARD THE FINAL VOTE IS EIGHT
ZERO. AND FILE ITEM TWELVE AB
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ZERO
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN HI THE
VOTE IS SIX ZERO. THANK YOU-
AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE HEARING.